- [Instructor] In other videos
we have first started talking
about the legislative branch
of the United States federal government.
We talk about how it has two houses,
the Senate that has 100 members,
two per state, two times 50,
and the House of Representatives
that has 435 members.
And states have a certain
number of representatives
depending on their population.
We're going to go into a little more depth
in this video is exactly
how laws get passed,
in particular how do bills get passed
by one or both of these houses.
And if you're looking at
the U.S. Capitol building
from the lawn, you can assume
that the Washington Monument
is behind you in this
picture right over here,
the Senate chamber is on the
left side, just like that,
and the House of Representatives
is on the right side.
Well, what does a bill actually look like?
So, right over here is
the cover of a House bill,
and notice some interesting things.
The House bill starts with H.R.,
House of Representatives 1.
And so this is the first
bill being introduced
in this first session
of the 108th Congress.
And it says, and it's
a little hard to read,
especially if you're looking
at this on a mobile phone,
but it says, to amend Title
XVIII of the Social Security Act
to provide for voluntary program
for prescription drug coverage
under the Medicare program to
modernize the Medicare program
and for other purposes.
So that's just a very quick summary.
And then it talks about
who are the representatives
that are introducing the bill.
So it's Mr. Hastert and
then it's in parentheses,
it says for himself and
then it says, Mr. DeLay,
Mr. Blunt, and it keeps
going on and on and on.
And this was introduced June 25, 2003.
And over here, the
bottom of where it talks
about who is introducing
this bill, it says,
which was referred jointly
to the Committee on Energy and Commerce,
and Ways and Means, in
each case for consideration
of such provisions as fall
within the jurisdiction
of the committee concerned.
So this is the first clue
of how bills get started.
In theory, anyone could write a bill,
in practice, they are written
by a member of Congress's
aides or aides of a committee,
and we're gonna talk
more about committees.
But they need to be formerly introduced
by members of Congress.
And you can see here Mr. Hastert,
Congressman Hastert is listed first.
But it doesn't go straight to a vote
by the full House of Representatives.
It will be introduced to
an appropriate committee,
which is a subset of the
House of Representatives.
In this case it's going to go to both
the Committee on Energy and Commerce
and the Ways and Means Committee.
We can similarly look at a Senate bill,
and it has some similarities.
And the key thing to appreciate is
that a bill could be introduced
into the House initially
or into the Senate initially.
And sometimes you have parallel bills
that are essentially trying
to do the same thing,
going through both
chambers at the same time.
But right over here,
this is a Senate bill,
Senate bill 1833, this
is in the 115th Congress,
to modify the requirements applicable
to locatable minerals
on public domain land
and for other purposes.
And then this is September 19th, 2017.
It says, Mr. Udall for himself,
and then it lists other senators,
introduced the following bill
which was read twice and
referred to the committee
on Energy and Natural Resources.
And then you start seeing
the text of the bill.
So once again, whether it
initially gets introduced
into the Senate or into the House,
the first place where it goes is
to the appropriate committee.
And in general, it will only get voted on
by the entire Senate or the entire House
if it is approved by a committee.
If a majority of the committee
actually votes for it.
Now what are these committees?
So in the House of Representatives,
you currently have over 20 committees
at the time that I'm making this video.
Right now you have 20 standing committees,
which means they are
continuously in operation,
and one select committee,
which means it might be created
for a special purpose,
although some of these select committees
tend to last for awhile.
Now what I'm gonna list here are some
of the most powerful committees
in the House of Representatives.
You have the House Ways
and Means Committee.
Now why is this important?
What is a Ways and Means?
This is the committee that
first considers legislation
around taxation.
So it's the ways and means
by which the government
can actually fund itself.
And so you can imagine this
is very, very powerful.
Who gets taxed, by how much,
how much revenue is actually coming in?
What will that do to the economy?
And this is a committee
that's very specific
to the House of Representatives.
In general, bills could be
introduced to the Senate
or the House or both.
But if it's something regarding taxation,
that has to originate in
the House of Representatives
and it will go through the
House Ways and Means Committee.
Another very powerful committee
is the Budget Committee.
Through tax policy, the House
Ways and Means Committee
influences how the
government gets its revenue,
but the Budget Committee decides
what is actually the
budget of the government.
The president can make a proposed budget,
but it's the budget committee
that actually decides
on what budget Congress will
actually vote on in the House.
Now, once you have a budget,
you have to think about
how you're gonna spend that money.
And that's what the Appropriations
Committee is focused on.
Which programs get how much funding?
So once again, this is a very
powerful committee to be on.
But perhaps the most
powerful committee of all is
the Rules Committee.
The reason why this is so powerful
is that in the House of Representatives,
even if a bill is
introduced into committee,
and even if that committee
decides to vote on that bill,
and let's say they pass
it by a simple majority,
it doesn't go straight to the floor
of the House of Representatives to a vote.
The Rules Committee is actually,
you can view them as the traffic cop
for the House of Representatives.
For the most part, they decide
which bills go to the floor
of the House, what are the rules
by which they are voted on.
Are people allowed to make amendments,
which are add-ons to that bill?
Are people even allowed to debate it?
They can even decide whether
it's going to be voted on
by the House of Representatives acting
as the House of Representatives,
or whether it's gonna be voted on
as the Committee of
the Whole, so to speak,
which is the entire
House of Representatives.
The difference between
voting for something
as a House of Representatives
or the Committee of the Whole,
in either case, it would
happen in the same room
is that there's different
procedures on how to do it.
And so you can imagine
there's a lot of strategy
depending on which party is in charge
on what initially even
gets through a committee,
and then once it gets through a committee,
what's the procedure
by which it is voted on
or whether it gets voted on at all.
Does it have a very public debate,
or is there very little debate?
Now, if something does pass the House,
then that same bill,
once it passes the House,
would have to be voted on by the Senate.
Now, similarly, in the Senate,
when a bill is introduced,
it goes to committee.
And in the Senate currently,
there are 16 standing committees
and over 20 total committees
at the time of this video.
And just to get a sense of some
of the more powerful
committees on the Senate,
you have things like the
Appropriations Committee,
which is a sister committee
of the House Appropriations Committee
that we talked about before.
Once again, they will
try to think about well,
how could that money be spent?
You have the Foreign Relations Committee.
One key distinction between
the Senate and the House,
there's a lot of areas where
they both might legislate on
or introduce legislation on,
but in general, tax bills can
only originate in the House,
while the Senate is closer to
things like foreign relations.
The Senate Foreign Relations Committee,
all treaties would go through them.
The Senate Armed Services Committee,
it has legislative
authority over the military.
Now once something gets through
any of these committees,
then it would go through the Senate floor.
And even there you start
to appreciate a difference
between the House and the Senate.
In the Senate, not only do you have
a fewer number of senators,
they tend to be more generalists
and it's easier for something
to get to the Senate floor.
It's a little bit more collegial.
In the House, if the majority
party is strongly controlling
the Rules Committee, they
can very strongly control
not just what gets to the floor,
but what is debated, how it's debated,
if it's debated and what
has amendments put on it.
And also, the members who
serve on these committees,
it's a little bit more specialized.
Now in either case, once a
bill gets through either house,
it has to be voted on by the other house.
So if a bill gets approved by the Senate,
then it will go to the House,
and if that same bill
is approved by the House
with a simple majority, then
it will go to the President.
Now the President might sign the bill,
in which case it would become law,
or the President could veto that bill.
If the President vetoes
the bill, it goes back
to both of these houses
and to override the veto,
each of these houses,
they both have to vote
with a 2/3 majority,
and that happens very seldom.
Now you also have a
scenario where sometimes
very similar bills are going
through both houses at the same time.
So there's a situation where
a similar bill has gone
through both houses at the same time,
what it goes to is something
called a conference committee.
And a conference committee is a group
of both senators and representatives
who will get together and
they'll try to reconcile
the differences between those two bills.
And once they get one bill
that reconciles the differences
between those two, then they'll go back
for a vote to both houses.
And if they pass both
houses, then once again,
it will go to the President
who could decide to sign it
or veto it, and once
again, if it gets vetoed,
that veto could get overridden.
So the big picture here is we've talked
about that policy making
process in previous videos
where at first you wanna identify an issue
and then you wanna do policy formulation.
Well, a lot of that is going
on in the U.S. Congress.
You have congressional aides
who are identifying problems,
maybe different constituents,
maybe lobbyists are saying,
hey, can you fix this
or can you change the
tax code in some way?
Then they formulate a policy
which is essentially these bills.
These bills are essentially
a policy formulation,
and then those policies
have to be adopted.
To be adopted, it has to be approved
by both houses of Congress
and then signed by the President.
Or if it's vetoed by the President,
that veto has to be overridden
by both houses of Congress.
And then it's up to the Executive Branch
to implement that policy.
I'll leave you there.
And in future videos we'll
talk more about the mechanics
of the U.S. Congress.